Danny Trejo welcome good morning good
morning so what I love about this
cookbook is you say these recipes uh are
easy food that's a celebration of life
absolutely what do you mean by that it's
just you know what people
it's hard to be
angry or at a good meal oh that's right
yeah that's right especially if you're
hungry yeah you automatically start like
feeling good I like people coming into
our restaurant I don't know how they
feel they leave feeling better that's
the way it is it's like coming coming
home and just having a great meal
sitting down yeah so you always say
think like a prisoner but cook like a
caterer yeah I love that it's a great
line he said look I was in prisoners
things yeah prisoners have to be what is
it like necessity is the mother of
invention yes you know so if you're
locked up and you're the guys that don't
get a visit right uh you all kind of get
together with a spread everybody breeds
something you mix it together really
good Cooks in there and hey be creative
yeah
wide Clifton Collins right and uh in
fact he was Pedro Gonzalez Gonzalez's
grandson who was one of the first real
Mexican actors right he worked with all
John Wayne movies but he wrote a book
actually that that features about 50
prison recipes wow from with Top Ramen
they called it Ramen yeah and that's
Ramen now that they took cigarettes out
of
[Laughter]
uh Cantina food is what you call it
right what is Cantina food for you you
know what back in the day when I was
like God four five six seven I used to
run around my uncles and my dad and they
all went again and they had they used to
have a big table with cold cuts and
potato salad and stuff and that's where
you would be drinking and go make
yourself a sandwich and eat and you
would be comfortable you're with your
friends that's the one we wanted to do
yeah we wanted to make it like that what
the thing I love about what you've done
here is most recipe books have a whole
section for cocktails and there is maybe
one non-alcoholic option and often none
right only recently is there some we've
been to over 50 years and you took a
very different approach here this is
non-alcoholic leading we uh I've been
almost 55 years wow and 54. I anyway I
but but literally
I my favorite drink okay is cranberry
juice and Sprite Cambridge that's what
you know so and uh and it's a lot of
times I don't like people why don't you
drink you
because I don't you know yeah yeah yeah
like Gail you probably get that question
so so we've what we've done is just
gotten
drinks mixed them you made made a whole
variety yeah let me have a uh you know
Tom Collins or whatever you want but
it's non-alcoholic no I like what you
say Danny you said I'm not anti-drinking
you're all for people to drink
responsibly you said you're anti-me
drinking exactly and that you don't need
booze you can still make a grown ass
sophisticated drink that tastes good I
like that and you know some it's funny
it's like when you go to a a dance
sometimes and you ask someone to dance
you know available
I haven't drank yet right right there's
a little judgment I don't need to drink
right right and a couple of my favorites
the blueberry muffin and to live in Rye
in L.A
but you have these Fight Night nachos oh
how are these different than regular if
you come to the house we'll change them
to football nachos okay I'm gonna hold
you to that all right I am showing up
but uh so what we do with our nachos the
problem with nachos is people put a bed
of chips and then they put the
ingredients on top well you know first
what do you do you eat all the
ingredients and you got a whole bed of
chips so what we did was we put a bed of
chips nachos that's what we're looking
at another bit of chips or nachos oh you
layer it up I like anybody who starts so
that way nachos
you end up with like getting that last
nacho and that last chip and picking up
Danny can we just talk about your face
it is so cool you play the bad guys so
well when did you yeah when did you know
you had that face that was just iconic
yeah iconic when did you know that that
face there could be
27 Mexicans standing on a corner and the
police would roll up yeah you come here
it was just just because of the way you
look and uh Danny Trejo the food is
amazing we're gonna drink this is the uh
Macho michelada yeah I'm looking forward
to having sipping this while we welcome
you and thank you for coming by thank
you cheers cheers
Bravo trailers Cantina is available now
wherever you really are your books